what's happen are you alright what's
happened to you are you okay I sprained
my ankle this morning honey but I wasn't
gonna miss this barrel favorite so I'm
like not gonna miss like well it's one
of my favorite shows but you know but
yeah try and big little lies I literally
sprained my silly little ankle this
morning and I just like had this out but
all right and I was like I'm not right I
was gonna wear like a different shoe but
um yeah I'm giving you Lisa turtle and
Saved by the Bell
realness did you sprain it during one of
your amazing gymnastics right I was
warming up firm I was warming up for
because I'd like I'm touring it so I was
warming up and hopefully she's gonna be
a little baby three toes to be a couple
he's gonna be fine I'm not one to sit
down long um yeah so and even if it's
not I totally have it on video so like
I'll figure out okay and stand interpret
yeah I'll do something it'll be great
what are you gonna say to Merrill today
I'm not I'm a just like a silent value
no yes alright last question we're doing
big a little lies season two when are we
getting queer i season four I mean I my
middle name is not spoilers
it is MacDonald I believe it or not such
a weird middle name is my grandma's main
name it's not that weird but yeah it's
not foot and I'm not gonna get in
trouble with our PR honey
[Music]